sua lógica de quem muito se mexe que é
bom o pessoal aqui quem fala é o dark
seja muito bem-vindo xuxa acham bem olha
aí vai não só pessoal eu me inspiro se
mexe muito com a equipe muito perto do
meu pai mas não podem ter noção de que
uma piada gigante onde existe já uma
grande confusão aqui
e pra quem não sabe o que são os méxico
se mexe é um brinquedo foi dentro de uma
bola que nós temos que tirar o chapéu e
essa bola vai partir pra e só aí é que
nós vamos poder ver o brinquedo que está
lá dentro
veja só atira a bola para abrir mais de
100 como ensinava sno cuecas hábito e
aqui fora inclusive já mostrou nenhum e
que tem mais dois surpresa que é isso
que temos que curtir no chão e depois
não só continua até este pec 4 não dois
de maggi pr com muitos colégios o ator
está muito alta e já saíram aqui dois
policiais
olha aí inclusive nós podemos colocar os
nossos méxico dentro desse caminho olha
que ele é quem manda é que eu não sei se
pensava eu acho que não explica a
estudante mas dentro desta linha black
um campo bastante com ela quero brincar
com estruturas muito ansioso olha só
como podem ver eu acho que tem aqui um
atirador se mexe e nós temos que acertar
aqui para além disso que ele nós também
temos aqui umas latas superespeciais eu
acho que aqui tem edições super caro é
porque tem vários brinquedos sem osso
pesados cujo edição limitada os bets
cortes são homens maus do desporto do
board of change tem tanta força que tem
muita qualidade mas que comandava a cura
eu ando à procura dos super raros olhem
mais para lá pessoal antes de começarmos
aqui e quebrar todas as bolas que eu
quero que vocês deixam muito à equipe
neste vídeo isso não foi inscrito no
canal e não escrevam vim para lá começar
a abrir
vamos começar pelo pec mais quentinha
pinhata vai ficar para o fim do vídeo
portanto não percam porque nunca coisa
olha só a componente lei mãe
a intenção é bater nisso e tudo está lá
dentro mas pude levar 500 brinquedos
- faço muito pouco só acompanhei até o
fim e agora nós vamos ter aqui um
desafio aos 1 transmitiu para vos correr
não se mexe muito masculino e vamos ver
qual deus eu passei eu vou votar na
equipa de fast food que é o silas se
pisar uma fatia de pizza que está aqui
embaixo voltar mesmo que eu adoro pisa e
piquete furiosa sabe como é que o soneto
eu adoro forró e tomou foi porque as
crianças quando o texto foi vai escolher
o bad boy é um dos maus é um desportista
o que é bicicleta só comentei em
basquete vai ganhar usar a bicicleta
usada piso vamos ver quem vai ganhar
embora ela confia na briga e vamos
começar a abrir um futuro muito ansioso
o jazz eo rock onde só há um caminho a
um triunfo por 111 é quem é enérgico
civis machos têm aqui um buraquinho pra
vocês colocarem em cima do que ninguém
gosta que um cachorro aqui um golo e ver
que uma cozinha outro jovem mulher é o
melhor do rock mas só vamos ver que o
nosso caminho depois mais tarde a
companhia acompanhe agora a nossa super
bolla se mexe
a partir de agora vamos nós passamos as
partes para 432 o brasil vive uma bota
uma bota de basquetebol
olha aí eu acho que está sendo eficiente
eu acho que por ter essas bolas mais
cedo muito viciante que o brinquedo não
sei se você já sai de fábrica aqui novo
regente cível em mim é super difícil não
sou o pessoal vai incluir este brinquedo
ainda brinquedo e agora vai ser com um
problema de perda óssea curaram
vamos lá vem mais sexo só tem aqui um
papel especial de 8 se mexe
já vim aqui pois tudo basquete 1 do
tênis mas este eu acho que não são raros
né porque senão não vi nada assim na
frente do pacote sério que nunca ganhará
piso fez tudo é que tem de dois que
vieram com esse aspecto fish até então
milton com muito dotado de ser eu gosto
eu acho que vai haver uma tarja com o
cocó aichi chocou é só que eu pensei em
qual o primeiro tucano e já sabem
pessoal retira para abrir uma brecha de
ser inscritos possa ir 12 da mesma
família prancha de surfe skate mil teus
com muita sorte muita sorte mas vamos lá
agora abrir duas do mesmo a acho que é
um pau de lado vamos abrir a próxima
meu deus isso é muito louco acho que
isso aqui é uma placa daquelas placas de
ver a vantagem no marcador é uma queda
da nota 14 25 aguentar a primeira que o
jogo em outra coisa que vocês podem
fazer também é colecionar esses mestres
na nossa aplicação podem baixar a
aplicação de fumacê usado bastante droga
não posso o iphone vocês podem baixar e
ver quais machos técnico jackson índice
em baixa vale a pena e agora vão dividir
os nossos dois mestres que ofertar o
uhuu é uma pisa do mal se uma fatia de
pizza do mal
assim isto é qual o brasil é um dos
maiores desportistas
este ep mar e olha só pisa tem dentro da
marel última bola tv uol o uol não é um
taco de beisebol com os técnicos e ano
bom com um toque do país o fórum abre
mais agora só vamos definir nossa
lutinha com se mexe eu acho que chita
que o colector sim a esta o ataque tem
50 personagens eu acho que todos aqui
são exclusivas
eu acho que não tem 50 aqui dentro eu
acho que podem ser de 50 fãs de ficção
vamos lá ver o que pode ser que em 321 1
ruiu seria só um evento tão especial
eu acho que é um especial olha aí o que
que ele é uma boa largada é uma bola que
se fosse uma guerra olha aí ela tá
povoar essa bola como assim vamos
guardar aqui este lado só porque estão
especial portanto vai ficar aqui do lado
e vamos destruir mas mecha só agora vou
ouvir dois pet de hoje vamos ver o que
tem aqui dentro
ontem aquilo que eu gosto muito com
lesões méxico e que tem mais uma bota de
basquete itens clima que lily allen e
islaine olha só já temos muitos ou ser
umas 2 a mesma bota e e bebida
energética mas com outras coisas só para
quem só que na embalagem de latinha com
aquela que eu abri a pouco vem mas
mexendo aqui e humor falei mas tem
outros que isso aqui tá tá embalados com
plásticos teve especial também só não
faço em casa o acidente provocou
confusão tática vamos sobre isso porque
se quisesse especial o ou é uma luva de
boxe com olhos muito louca eu vou ver
qual a envolver qual é curva do boxee
box
olha não pode ser um dos atacantes é um
destaque atacante michel roque e taco de
beisebol é muita coisa que dá pra casa
então este é dos bondes bom vamos abrir
mais mestres do que quer fazer uma super
puma que se mexa mais dois
aqui vai uma tão lisa olha só é baliza e
muito menos 10 acumular muitos aqui mais
uns beijos mas não fecha
assim o cartão vermelho ea série é o
problema do futebol
falei meu pé é um cartão vermelho mas de
um cartão amarelo e não faz sentido sua
mostra de que muitos flashes e em 32 um
salto muito alto e precisa de uma baliza
com outra cor
mas o que sinto mais music muito mas não
só
silva que usa bolinha com rosa uma bola
do time mas eu acho que faltaram mais
tryp hotels sol é muito grande porque
estamos ficando maluco e colei e um
capacete do jogador do clube é muito
grande muito gordo esse brinquedo
municipal e contou que escolheu acho que
a equipa dos equipamentos de choques com
que os franceses banco tem muita fez
mechas abençoam já sabe o quanto é
difícil mas temos o que mais mexe mais
fede show ou é um disco de rock achou
mais um mais uma prancha de surf session
e choro e olha só mais uma prancha do
skype estão inscritos mais uma voltinha
branca uma rua e este é outro atacante
olha isso e só parou muito profissão eu
vou ganhar eu vou apanhar o olho que sem
um louco é que eu sempre consigo apanhar
um brinquedo que os coja com suas forças
e conseguir ganhar um brinquedo que eu
procurava e aqui consegui também já pode
estar apostando na loja nós combinamos
visível que sim mas mais uma bola do
riso e é stay dos mal sabendo que só
muito bem infantil ok dok os bichos aqui
uma raquete maluco é que tal se nós
pegarmos aqui na nossa raquel piltcher
as mechas olha e segue para lá mas mexe
é um tipo de curso para dizer lhe que
deixe por isso ea exato tirava seu
primeiro brinquedo a lei mas ninguém
vermelho e agora olha a questão da
altura vai ser difícil pra mim na outra
e só assim só de ver dois foi obrigado a
mexer em 2001 já estava no chão
2 não é tão panfleto é numérico é assim
o herói agora 32 vai pessoal sim mais
uma bola los a educação isso que estou
num exercício físico ela acha que agora
pessoal vamos estar aqui o nosso carinho
de mechas agora aqui isso vai ficar
entre santo nós podemos jogar aqui
futebol é dentro do nosso que linha ou é
super bowl o tufo especial olha só o bom
é um dedo é um bebê que foi o mais
especial aqui um outro carro que eu já
tenho casa aqui também e agora vamos lá
meu deus eu estou muito curioso ok eu
acho que já não interessa já não
interessa mais é só questão que o passe
colagem tudo parece claro tem muito que
é tão sério o ecoponto vai ficar sim mas
por um lapso ao nosso carinho desses
mexe chance e agora como é que isto é
obra
esse é o nosso campo de batalha se mexe
como funciona as tinha muito tempo aqui
já tive toc estabiliza nos colocaram
aqui uns mexe eu falei só acho que isso
mas eu preciso da nossa bola nós temos
aqui uma bola vai experimentar a nossa
bola com fogo e acho que sim nem 321 mãe
muito
faltou muito campo 3 do mundo a quando o
hu hospital para lá agora experimentar
só a nossa bola amarelo vamos ver se ela
marca boom da mesma forma ballack
deposto e en 321 bairro gay foi o gol
mais bonito e agora 32 um vai levar r
entrou como substituto do júri tudo
jogador experimentar outra mesmo vai ver
o que virá agora deu a louca com o
jogador de futebol em 32 culpa muito bem
o que o senhor musculado não lá no clipe
uma casa fora do eixo o deus do futebol
paraibano em 32 ruas méxico tem que ser
na bola amarela é manuel thomaz 36 32
rua tom ópera foi chamado por ela agora
pessoal montar o nosso queridinho eu
acho que estou fazendo assim
vejam só é e 30
além dele o único em que o nhoque e
agora nós temos que ter aqui
participantes que o inep não vamos
colocar todo já que ensina olha só o que
vocês podem notar a vossa equipa olha só
a não prender o piloto conseguiu
escrever que conduziu nosso caminho
acho que vai ser via láctea é o nosso
melhor amigo carro porque como tema a
experiência conduzida pode ser o
contorno só para não ver o acidente mas
o que é que vai ao lado vai o senhor do
boxe luva de boxe por e por tentarem
roubar o carro os meus votos do tejo
segundo carro deixa eu penso em tudo que
eu sou um gênio e se está a bicho e até
agosto contra a porta da lei e agora vou
reunir aqui muitos machos porque por
conquistar wii está a ajudar eu vou
tirar muitas dimensões possível e ver a
reação dele vai ficar chateado mas
quando eu souber que são brinquedos pode
ser fixo isso então vamos reunir aqui um
montão dos machos
e não esqueça o foco no fim do vídeo
ainda temos é pinhata portanto ainda tem
mais por vir
olha só olha só eu e deus é bem
divertido excluir os bons vamos abrir
mais um pacote eu acho que sinto
além desta data só mais um olha e e
agora se o cartão amarelo cuca também
não o pessoal eu acho que são bolas
suficiente
olha só é porque nestas duas para que
muitas novas dentro do dólar
[Música]
em 32 ruas mexa sem um brinquedo mel sem
um brinquedo mucho más nem parece que
qualquer pessoa não pode perder portanto
vamos embora vamos oferecer um pacote
melhor amiga montanha embora o minuto a
minuto cuba ocupa duas áreas que sempre
procura o amor é lindo é bom pois nada é
tão legal
nada nada ligam
ae
só fiquei muito cansado mas agora sim é
é brincadeira aberturas mechas uma só
temos aqui uma super pinhata com muita
coisa dentro de mim muita coisa aqui
dentro por isso aí como é que nós vamos
destruir esta pinhata com o nosso super
taco de pinhata que eu não tinha que
estar aqui ó
mas para nós concluirmos esta opinião e
vou pra sala que tem muito mais fácil lá
e foram lá e agora o pessoal exagera
luta dotar frango cientista contra a
cunhada para lá
eu vou correndo igual
as filas culpa você né
[Música]
[Aplausos]
acho que não vai
o encontro visa ser uma televisão aí que
o banco tem muito brinquedo no chão
coisas são três grupos
eu vou lá em cima por dia como esse que
está aí machuquei meu espírito de manter
em cima tá tudo da silva embora numa
pizza é uma pizza de mussarela estourado
na hipótese durava pessoal inclusive tem
nenhumas para aguentar aqui e vai muito
mais embolado olha só temos muito mais
mas as fotos para que elas tenham estado
aqui deste vídeo já sabem se quiserem
ver mais vídeos e assim a brinquedos
cometer de quando vocês comprarem as
mechas ligam-se sigla pg dourada ainda
até porque eu quero saber quantas
pessoas que também têm equipes e dourada
a equipe do fecho e eu agora tenho
muitos começam na sala porque agora vou
ter que apanhar a kyoto mas até agora
nós temos um super rápido uma porta
dourada então tudo valeu a pena pois
deixei muito mais do que nos pires pt no
estado fiquem bem até a próxima semana
[Música]